welcome to my office how long have you
guys been holed up in here a few days we
found a bit of food though here ya le
airs pretty good too blueberries found a
whole stash of them you want something
no mm relax we're safe so why haven't
you left been waiting for the right
opportunity and here check this out what
look these sons of [ __ ] every day
they congregate down their garden that
damn bridge come nighttime is down to a
skeleton curdle after sunset that's a
window Muslim gone sneak right past them
I could work Oh it'll work it'll
definitely work yeah they would require
over there all right ready no blueberry
it's been a while since that boy even
cracked a smile she doesn't seem
bothered by all this catches in fact
that so where were you heading for the
fireflies face Weston where we're gonna
join up something funny dogs it seems
like there's a lot of people putting
their stock on the fireflies these days
yeah maybe there's a reason for that so
you don't know where they are and you're
just gonna drag him across the country
to find him that's what he s I'll tell
you what how about I worry about my
brother you worry about your girl
easy we're looking for the fireflies too
I let her Boston this is us there's an
abandoned military radio station just
outside the city any survivors from our
group they're supposed to meet us there
tomorrow you and your girl you won't
join us it goes down the night oh shet I
guess we best rest up then ok ok no can
try and kiss me he says it's time to go
Ella did his sleep did you just sucking
did assault on re the magazine's you
nobody moving fast ok so no matter what
you stick to me like glue likely like
glue guy good good all right y'all ready
like that sprout yeah y'all rad ok ok
I'm ready y'all stay close okay you
tried this before uh yeah that's company
he's [ __ ] liar max old man I've sadly
no the way the hell is in here thank ya
take these working I'm working on my
watch working on building up and i watch
so that's why i keep taking these things
just messing a few parts the thing
that's just little fishes not yet okay I
love it on my chef at my bow now and a
little sad right ok let's try to take
him out quietly hey you hear something I
came from over there [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
i hear [ __ ]
what the hell oh I got him holy [ __ ]
how do i hear like [ __ ] zombies where
is this guy I know you heard that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on out there oh
[ __ ] oh uh okay that ended up like
[ __ ] horrible
my arrows back sir oh yeah might as well
switch it out yeah bye-bye
how [ __ ] awful was I
nice thing either here
because this is that
okay i can think on these guys oh ok
thank you make really i canna how to get
out se on door I guess
bonded us minus time to hide behind your
joke is the dial nightlife see
I'd say chef can't say [ __ ] here you
kill one [ __ ] where is he I just heard
him you're gonna match out out
ok where's that one [ __ ]
where z 0 pockets shed
we did it yeah you mean I did it okay
cuz I don't think you killed one person
jose okay i don't think he killed one
person and i'm saying this because I'm
trying here and you know I'm just a
little upset that it was kind of all my
ammo do you know what i mean by that
like it's a little upset hose I a little
upset that's all I'm saying could have
tried a little harder le give me
something Ali I'm dying alicante sound
dying hey [ __ ] yeah I go up there no I
can't yeah now darn it [ __ ] here hey
[ __ ] there ok well may-maybe then we'll
give it to me if I'm like half health
kill me
shut my dinger out these days okay oh
Henry give me a hand with this all right
you ready okay so who should God come on
everyone my hands are those here this
mess yet yeah joe up there I got it go
go check it out yep side we're good Sam
let's go dang already makeable there in
a ram it come here naran we at these
guys don't leave us behind hurry
okay we gotta get a moment I'm sorry
we're leaving what [ __ ] hey now what
the [ __ ] Henry guys are poly high we
stick together
how I come on
come on in there
look at aiding in here take can I gotta
hurry yeah okay okay good good okay well
now's not time to be quiet it so [ __ ]
Haley cover me [ __ ] no [ __ ] who
happened right now whoo that hurt I'm on
a fight fight like a man like a little
girl let's see we could scavenge pretty
good right don't let it go to your head
let it go to theirs did you just call me
a piece of [ __ ] girl I think you just
call me a piece of shet make me I don't
like that okay we hit the tone some shut
up will ya yes
Katya psych LP little day you think
Erica dance and yeah i miss the head
okay whose fear would put this thing
where the [ __ ] was it like here I'm not
really sure what it's trying to get us a
deal
oh how can i push it back here no oh
right there Pakistan okay I can't okay
[ __ ] sucks room figure out what all
right hmm hey mr. Shatner I'll let me
get this thing be sure that was the
perfect thing to do how's it kept Chat
Chat Chat Chat
shut hi holy [ __ ] [ __ ] halls how many
policy have left you're gonna kill where
the choice do we have we jump no it's
too high and you can't swim I'll boost
you up your own pastor you keep me
afloat Ellie
argue Ali
it's out for her Rob